c'est pas si vous le savez mais c'est la
journée mondiale de la résolution des
conflits et à sare du calendrier
hier sur ce plateau un clash a fait les
choux gras de la presse française
il a eu lieu entre deux chroniqueurs
gilles verdez et valérie bénaïm eh bien
nous allons essayer de résoudre ce
conflit aujourd'hui
et quand deux personnes ne se supportent
plus quant au dialogue est devenu
impossible
bref quand il n'y a plus de solution on
appelle qui on appelle baballe grand
frère des voix si valérie bénaïm une
mère de famille bienveillante working
girl et blogueuse à mi-temps à l'épi que
derrière ce sourire angélique se cache
une femme qui sait ce qu'elle veut
un petit verdot valérie lui c'est gilles
verdez journalistes spécialisés dont
sport mais faits divers et les bacs de
mariage le public le connaît pour ses
excès de colère pourtant dans la vie il
est beaucoup plus calme fois encore
payées dans ce pays et tout le temps
c'est une bagnole d'hommes avec une
couleur d'hommes en fin de mois de la
fesci
hier soir ne touche pas à mon poste
alors que tout semblait bien parti c'est
le drame 6 à chaque fois que quelqu'un
dit une connerie
bon on le sanctionne poitrine et ce
jusqu'en 2000 2004 j'ai déjà tenu des
propos
je n'ai pas voté j'ai pas dit qu'il
tenait des propos sexistes ai dit tu
pour te dit notant les conneries seule
solution faire intervenir le plus grand
médiateur du pav baba le grand frère
valérie bénaïm et gilles verdez vous
avez à une minute trente dites-vous tout
dit vous les choses hier ça s'est très
mal passé entre vous je vous le dis et
juste après j'ai une image vous allez
voir vous allez crever c'est parti on y
va valérie bénaïm démarrer pourquoi vous
êtes énervé après gilles verdez parce
qu'à chaque fois que tu dis une connerie
et si on te payait tuterai
multimillionnaire c'est quoi votre plus
gros problème benhaim c'est que vous
êtes aussi lisse que votre brushing
hier je t'aurais pas mis à la mode
vous aimez tellement les boulettes que
vous en faites toute la journée bénin
rapport c'était obligé de dieu et c'est
pour masquer le vide intersidéral de ton
cerveau importante pour l'émission quand
vous n'êtes pas là la déco n'est pas
pareil trend est battu c'est quoi c'est
un état vraiment un si gros nez tu sais
pourquoi tu sais pas ce que tu as tout
le monde dans le pif
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il est tout seul le soir il a
pas vous supportez beinheim est battu
c'est quoi ta vraiment de la chance toi
parce que je t'aime quand même je vous
pardonne
il
ça peut
[Applaudissements]
il a fait chaud le fond
merci mal aimé vallat et merci gilles
verdez bon vous aimez break mais oui
monsieur hier samedi pocho ça va mieux
ça va bien ça va mieux
c'est ça le bleu la force de touche pas
à mon poste on se dit des choses on
n'est pas forcément d'accord mais on
s'aime quand même et on arrête de dire
des conneries quand même